lluís finalizan estas votaciones cómo se
desarrolló la jornada
buenas tardes así es valentina esto es
corferias y es el punto más grande de
votación de colombia donde los
ciudadanos han podido venir desde las 8
de la mañana y hasta las 4 de la tarde
como comentabas la jornada ha
transcurrido con relativa calma sin
incidentes mayores pero sí que en horas
de la tarde el ministerio el interior
había reportado más de 600 quejas
ciudadanas también la registraduría el
órgano que se encarga de organizar estos
comicios ha tenido fallos técnicos como
la caída de la página web también
ciudadanos que han venido a los puntos
de votación se han encontrado estos ha
visto las redes en quejas con que no
aparecían sus nombres y no han podido
votar también ha habido incidentes entre
agentes armados y fuerzas de la ley
aislados en algunas zonas rurales del
país y la verdad sí que te puedo
comentar un poco el ambiente de la
jornada después de hablar con personas
que están aquí depositando el voto y se
siente en bogotá concretamente que
tienen ganas de cambio pero habrá que
esperar a los resultados definitivos
para ver si esto se confirma louis y
justamente a qué hora se empezarán a
conocer resultados y también le preguntó
si ya hay datos de la participación o de
resultados en el extranjero sabemos que
cerca de un millón de personas estaban
habilitadas para votar en el exterior
empiezo por esta última pregunta y es
que aunque no tengamos datos certeros sí
que sabemos que la cancillería ha dicho
que ha subido el flujo de votantes en el
exterior esto se puede deber a una de
las novedades de estas elecciones como
son las consultas interpartidistas de
las que van a salir los principales
candidatos de la izquierda con el pacto
histórico del centro con la coalición de
la esperanza y de la derecha con equipo
por colombia que precisamente serán
estos los primeros resultados que se
conozcan de estas consultas
interpartidistas a partir de las 6 de la
tarde para después conocerse los del
congreso de cómo quedará conformado
tanto el senado como la cámara de
representantes y donde podremos
confirmar si ese cambio que piden si ese
fenómeno petro ese candidato de la
izquierda es tal como han augurado los
sondeos o si por el contrario también el
centro democrático el partido de
gobierno del presidente gandul que sufre
el revés electoral después de un
gobierno muy cuestionado en los últimos
años